[Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  i wandered  lonely as a cloud that floats on high or  veils and hills  when all at once i saw a crowd a host  of golden daffodils  beside the lake beneath the trees  fluttering and dancing in the breeze  continuous as the stars that shine and  twinkle on the milky way  they stretched in never-ending line  along the margin of obey  ten thousand saw eye at a glance tossing  their heads in sprightly dance  the waves beside them dance but they out  did the sparkling waves in glee  the poet could not but be gay in such a  jock and company  i gazed and gazed but little thought  what wealth the show to me had brought  for oft when on my couch i lie in  vacant or impensive mood they flash upon  that inward  eye that is the bliss of solitude and  then my heart  with pleasure fills  and dances with the daffodils  you